[Music]
all right welcome to the smartphone
Awards 2023 a lot of smartphones come
out every year and this year is no
different we got all kinds of shapes and
sizes and features and budgets just a
ton of phones and so like clockwork at
the end of the year you can count on me
to pick some favorites in each of the
categories that I break it down in so
this is a summary of the best and some
of the worst phones of 2023 and these
are my picks I always know I'm going to
get some push back on some of the
categories I'm sure I'll hear it in the
comments and I'm fine with that but
these are my picks so I'm sticking with
them so the way this works is I'm going
to break this down into the usual
categories every single category is
going to have one winner and then of
course there can be a runner up and
maybe some honorable mentions if we're
feeling generous and every single
category we've actually had custom
trophies made to get give to the winners
and lately the companies that win these
actually do request them and sometimes
end up displaying them in their
headquarters or whatever they're into
which is super cool for the recognition
so we're doing it again so without any
further Ado let's get started with our
first category best big smartphone so
this is a fun one just because you know
smartphones have been growing over the
years and they've started to get bigger
and bigger but at the point we're at now
it does kind of feel like they've
stopped growing am I the only one that
feels this way I feel like everyone sort
of agreed that we're not going to go
past 7in screen size everything over
that is ridiculous and so all these big
companies have their giant best
smartphones pushing right up against the
7in screen size and trying to fit as
much as possible in that phone so
there's a lot of competition in this
particular
category and my winner for the best big
phone the best use of that space in
2023 that's going to the Samsung Galaxy
S 23 Ultra once again the phone that
comes out at the beginning of the year
kind of a sleeper but it holds study the
entire year the design is obviously
pretty understated which I think is why
it goes under the radar these days but
it has all the hardware you could
possibly want it's got that corner to
corner 6.8 in display that's super
bright Quad HD ltpo 120 HZ it's also got
quad cameras on the back it's got a
5,000 milliamp battery it's got the
second latest generation Snapdragon ship
because it again it came out in January
and it also has room for a stylus inside
Without Really sacrificing anything so
yeah this thing is full of hardware and
it's also gotten software updates all
year with a bunch more promised it's
hard to pick if there's one standout
feature it might not be the huge 1440p
screen it might not be the 200 megapixel
main camera but I actually think it's
the massive Zoom for anyone that cares
about shooting subjects really far away
this camera system basically still feels
unmatched it feels kind of boring but it
does feel like that's a pretty clear
pick for me for best big phone of 2023
but I do have a runner up and this one's
not so obvious uh because again you kind
of get to blur the lines a bit with
these new phones that have been coming
out but I'm giving my runner up for best
big phone to the OnePlus open it
definitely deserves a mention because
when it's open there's almost an 8 in
square display this phone even in this
new folding form factor has all the
hardware you could possibly want and all
the software features to match and I
really enjoyed using this phone this
year despite how gigantic it is uh but I
do also want to give honorable mentions
for best big phone to Asus Rog Phone 7
and Oppo Find X6 Pro not that these
phones are like lacking anything again
the boring one one but you know if maybe
this one had wireless charging or if
this one had more zoom it could have
been in contention but these are two
also excellent giant phones that came
out this year so then next up category
best compact smartphone best small phone
this one I swear the pickings get
Slimmer every single year because not
only are smartphones getting bigger and
bigger but also even the smallest phones
are getting further and further from
small like the smallest phones from the
biggest companies are still what do you
want to call a pixel 7A small that's a
6.1 in screen or maybe Galaxy s23 the
Baseline one that's also a 6.1 in screen
it's tough to find a truly small phone
that brings all the flagship features
down but luckily there's one that really
did it and so it definitely deserves
this award the best small phone you saw
this coming already it's the Asus
zenphone 10 this is the flagship that
packs everything you need and More in an
actually one-h handable phone with a 5.9
in display so it deserves to be the
winner and I'm so glad that this phone
exists when I reviewed the Zen phone 9
last year I said it was pretty close to
perfect it was just missing a couple
things that had a couple small nitpicks
when I reviewed the Zen phone 10 this
year they fixed those nitpicks they
added wireless charging they made the
back of the phone more durable some
software tweaks it's literally nearly
perfect if you are thinking about buying
a small phone honestly it feels like
this may be one of the last good ones
you ever get to buy if you're if you're
in the age of wanting a mini phone speak
now or forever hold your cash cuz
they're they're going away the only
other phone that I think could
technically qualify for this it would be
some of the folding phones or flipping
phones I should say
uh Chief among them being Samsung's
zflip 5 now when you open up the phone
you're still getting a pretty big screen
it's a 6.7in screen when you actually
use a Z flip 5 but as many of you have
pointed out you can fold it down and
stow it in a much smaller form factor
than the others so even though it's not
the most one-h handable thing in the
world it's smaller so shout out to the Z
flip 5 honorable mention so next
category best camera in a smartphone in
2023 and this one I have a soft spot for
just cuz I like cameras and you guys
already knew that but there's been a lot
of really interesting stuff pushing the
boundaries for smartphone cameras in the
past year especially a lot of it
optically with really cool Hardware a
lot of it with software with processing
with AI with all the stuff we I mean I I
might end up making an entire video on
just how crazy it's gotten because
there's been some really interesting
stuff lately but my pick for best camera
for 2023 Ruffles feathers every time for
some reason but I really believe in this
one you already know it's the iPhone 15
Pro this is my camera King and I have
absolutely no regrets about it now the
simple fact that many people love to
point out is yes there are some
smartphones even ones on this table that
can produce better photos than the
iPhone in certain situations especially
Zoom but when it comes to just the
totality of performance across the
biggest variety of situations and ease
of use for photos and
videos the iPhone is still King
especially with video I feel like it's
still not particularly close the iPhone
takes the best most consistent usable
videos in the biggest variety of
situations of any SmartPhone by a long
way they also added log recording to the
pro iPhones this year they can also
record directly to an external SSD there
was an Apple keynote earlier this year
that turned out to be shot completely on
the iPhone and it looked incredible uh
but some of you may already remember and
I've pointed this out that that's not
the first time that's happened already
Samsung years ago did a keynote that was
live that was actually already shot and
they announced it on the phone uh but
you could tell like it wasn't it wasn't
nearly as good you really could tell so
this thing has been producing incredible
results basically if you told me I could
only have one smartphone camera for the
next 5 years I think I would pretty
quickly just go all right let's just
send it with the iPhone 15 Pro uh I do
also want to give an honorable mention
though uh to the Galaxy s23 Ultra this
thing especially because of how well it
does with the zoom has been an awesome
Stills camera for a long time really
good it also uh I I did a whole video on
it reviewing it the 200 megapixel thing
didn't turn out to be as big of a
difference versus the 100 megapixels as
we might have thought but in general
really good and then a shout out to the
winners of our scientific blind
smartphone camera test that we ran
online again this year we collected from
20 smartphones that came out in 2023 and
the overall most popular winner for the
standard photo was the pixel 7A then the
winner for low light photos was the
iPhone 15 Pro and the winner for
portrait photos was the pixel 8 Pro so
next category next winner is best value
sort of shifted over the years it used
to be best budget phone but I sort of
expanded it best value option here and
this is actually I think the hardest one
for me to pick Believe It or Not which I
think is a good thing and a bad thing
it's a good thing because it means
there's some competition in the high
value options but it's also not that
good of a thing just because a lot of
phones have gotten price hikes this year
there have been base prices going up
things that used to win budget awards
are more expensive now so I got to make
that decision on what qualifies as best
value like we all think a $1,000 phone
should not win best value right even if
it's a great phone so but how high is
too high but after much deliberation I
eventually landed on what feels like a
sweet spot a phone with basically no
standout features but also basically
nothing wrong with it the phone can be
found consistently for well under $400
it's the Samsung Galaxy a54 it's
everything you need and nothing you
don't like you could go more premium and
get more features and feel like you're
enjoying the phone more but you could
also go a little cheaper ER and start to
notice a little bit more Corner cutting
but this does a really good job of
striking the balance right in the middle
you know how when someone asks you like
how your day is Banning you just kind of
go it was fine nothing really happened
it was all right nothing
notable that's this phone cameras are
fine battery it's fine the screen it's
fine the design is fine everything is
fine so for 400 bucks you'll be just
fine uh I also want to give an honorable
mention though because there is a phone
that dipped way down below what I
thought a really good phone could be and
that is the Moto G play I reviewed this
phone as it came out at
$169 and to be honest I was very
impressed with it and kind of evaluating
the whole idea of how a phone could be
decent at this price 90 HZ and
everything but I'll also give a shout
out to the pixel 7A as you probably
remember the price went up this year all
the way up to 500 bucks uh but it did
gain some stuff it has a 90 HZ display
now it has better specs and it still
does all the stuff that you expect from
a pixel so it deserves a shout out for
being a good phone at that price so then
next up best battery best battery
overall in a smartphone this doesn't
necessarily go to the one that just has
the highest battery capacity I'm more
giving uh best overall battery
experience award ideally you also have
some decently fast charging or wireless
charging or it's just convenient that it
lasts for so long it might not actually
be the biggest sell I don't know that
anyone's actually buying a phone just
because it has the absolute best battery
life but if you do live that life that
no worries away from a charger life
you'll probably care about the winners
of this category so my winner who's
getting the trophy for best battery this
year is iPhone 15 plus specifically this
thing just goes and goes and goes the
bigger battery in general has a lot to
do with it the 60 HZ display also has a
lot to do with it but if you want a
risk-free no-brain or great battery life
that's definitely going to get it done
for you I'm also going to give a shout
out to the Rog Phone 7 it doesn't have
wireless charging but it does have
pretty fast charging and it has the
biggest battery capacity of any phone
I've used this year
6,000 milliamp hours and if you drop it
down to 60 HZ it will also just go and
go and go and also another Asus phone
which is the Zen phone 10 this one kind
of feels like wizard likee I don't know
how because it's not the biggest battery
it is pretty aggressive at killing
background apps and it's probably
missing some bands in the US so that
might have something to do with it but
this phone this small 5.9in displayed
phone it's killer battery life it can be
a two-day phone and you can drop it down
to 60 HZ as well so whatever Asus is
doing over there keep it up because
battery life is great I recently talked
about this in my hot takes video about
how phones are getting more and more
powerful but generally the average
battery life hasn't really changed that
much it's just been all day is good so
it's good to see some phones actually
pushing that envelope and they deserve
to get rewarded for it so then best
design this this one is so tough every
time best design because first of all
design is subjective like something I
find pretty you might find ugly fine but
also just in general it feels like every
phone has some flaw some reason why I I
I can't give it to that one like think
about it if you're in my shoes you got
to give a design Award right first of
all a lot of phones look pretty similar
to the way they did the previous year
right so I can't give it to one that
looks exactly the same as last year but
also I can't give it to one that has
some fatal flaw if it's missing a camera
it should have had or if it's missing if
it has a crazy bezel I can't give it to
the one with the biggest notch or or
dynamic Island can I I can't give it to
the one that's made of plastic or the
one that has a curved display on the
edges like what is what is an actually
Flawless maybe it's the most boring
design but you don't want to give the
design award to the most boring Design
This is a hard one and then it hit me
there was a phone this year that
basically made headlines just for its
design in a good way and I agreed with
them and it absolutely deserves a trophy
for design this year it's the honor
magic V2 this thing right here this
phone legitimately shifted the way I
think about phone Hardware it was like a
gear shift in the world of foldable
phones I think a lot of us didn't even
realize that you could make a phone like
this that has first of all it's under 10
mm thick when it's closed which is the
same thickness as plenty of regular
phones it has a fulls sizee screen on
the outside it has a corner to corner
foldable display on the inside it
somehow also fits a 5,000 Mah total
battery which I think is the biggest
I've seen in any foldable toss in 60
plus watt charging a triple camera setup
a terabyte of internal storage I think a
lot of us didn't realize this was
possible so even though the rest of the
phone might be a little questionable
maybe some weird software that I
wouldn't want to use the one thing that
nobody can question is the design
everyone I've shown it to universally is
impressed in some way by it but that
actually brings us to our first new
category ad in a long time in the
smartphone Awards and that is best
foldable phone so this is the first time
genuinely separating out and considering
ing all of the folding phones that came
out during the year and the reason it's
getting its own category this year is
because there's genuinely a large
variety of shapes and sizes and versions
of foldable phones and flippable phones
that we can choose from so I think in
general and I made a video talking about
this already but folding phones aren't
quite on the doorstep yet like they're
close but they're still mostly thicker
and more expensive than normal phones
but I do want to reward the ones that
are pushing the boundaries in some way
towards that Revolution so winner for
best foldable phone in
2023 yeah that's that's the OnePlus open
man this phone is good when I was
thinking about what I would personally
daily drive from the folding phones
Bunch this is the one that bubbled to
the Top This is the folding phone I
would be most likely to use when it's
closed it feels the most like a normal
phone mostly because the aspect ratio
and the size of the screen is normal
phone is flat sides but then you open it
up and it's a nearly 8 in almost
perfectly Square folding screen with a
very minimal crease awesome specs really
good software and a lot of fun features
to back it up I think my favorite part
is just the way you can move around
multiple windows and keep them full size
and have them overlap sort of the edge
of the screen it's it's a fun and unique
like actually new way of multitasking on
a phone and it actually works this was
the best phone with a folding screen
that was released during 2023 no doubt
about about that it's also basically the
exact same Hardware as the Oppo Find N3
fold so shout out to that one as well
but I also want to give an honorable
mention here I'm going to actually say
it's the runner up in this category of
best foldable uh to the pixel fold and
that's just because this one
specifically is my favorite foldable to
use closed because the outside screen is
so good the outside screen is nice and
compact it's the most reachable it's the
the smallest also but it's it's wide
it's big it's it's super useful to use
clothes and for whatever reason I love
that about it I don't know if that's a
good thing or a bad thing that I opened
it way less but it's the best to use
closed and I'm going to give an
honorable mention as well to Samsung's
zflip 5 I mentioned it earlier in this
video but a couple things about this one
is it feels like it's leading the pack
for the flipping phones I think it's
better than the Razer I think it's
better than some of the other flipping
ones but also as far as build quality
and just quality control Samsung in
general is at the top of the Heap
basically every other folding phone has
had some level of quality control issues
at some point and some rate and Samsung
ironically the ones that had the biggest
issues at the beginning have ironed it
out the most over time so that's their
reward for jumping in early also I have
to give that honorable mention to the
honor magic V2 just purely for the
design still can't believe they made
this phone super impressive so next
award most improved the most improved
award H you know it's it's interesting
because again lots of phones play it
safe lots of phones are just a slight
Evolution from last year they're a
slight spec bump and I can't get mad
that if they're already a good phone
like Zen phone for example I'm happy
they kept a lot of things the same but
then that makes the most improved a word
a little more um a little more of a
quirky pick maybe not the most obvious
pick in the world but I'm going to go
with the nothing phone 2 most improved
phone 2023 so this is part A Hardware
story and part of software story so
obviously they didn't change the
hardware a ton from the first nothing
phone because they're literally brand
new so they're just getting their
identity set so yeah there's a newer
higher resolution LED pattern on the
back there's a slightly curved glass now
to feel a little better in the hand but
generally it still looks like a nothing
phone but they also did a lot with the
software specifically moving to nothing
o OS 2.0 and then 2.5 which is now on
Android 14 which gets a lot of new stuff
with this phone there's a focus on
efficiency and smoothness and then
adding all these features and the
results have been fantastic so you
combine that with the new specs the
slightly bumped design and then a bunch
of the new features that unfortunately
the phone one isn't getting like the
better glyph controls and clone app
Feature and monochrome theme and stuff
it just adds up to a pretty big
Improvement to the point where in this
world of most people just being able to
buy last year's phone and be totally
fine with this phone I would actually
say don't buy last year's phone you
should just get the phone 2 or the phone
one plus you can send blue bubbles to oh
wait sorry never mind you can't do that
but still phone 2 much improved it's
probably going to study out after this
and this was nice to put them on the map
but now they'll have to stabilize and
become a real company and you know what
honorable mention just because I don't
know if anyone else can say they've
technically made this big of a change in
their phone as much as switching the
iPhone 15 to USB type-c so iable mention
to the iPhone all right next up bust of
the year the award you don't really want
to have to give but one of these phones
on this desk is going to win worst new
phone of 2023 look I do have to preface
this basically every time by saying it
is actually genuinely hard now to get a
bad phone like most phones no matter
what price point you're at are either
going to be really good for the money or
okay for the money it's hard to get a
bad
phone but there was one bad phone this
year and so it's going to win a trophy
for it and that would be the salana Saga
crypto phone bust of the Year there is
actually no price that I would recommend
anyone buys this phone buying this phone
is like buying a time share it might
seem like a good idea for like 2 seconds
but the second you actually do it you
realize how horrible of an idea it was
and this is just a bad phone the one
redeeming quality is actually it does
have this like nice build quality it's
got ceramic and it's nice and weighty
and heavy but yeah that was wasted on
this phone you could tell because of the
story behind it that it wasn't going to
go well I'll leave a link below to the
full video I did about it if you have an
itch to just hear about something
horrible but that's a pretty clear one
for bust of the year I'm also going to
give an honorable mention to all of the
concept cep phones that were announced
this year and never came out and never
will you know who you are so that brings
us to the biggest trophy of the night
well it's the same size as the other
trophies but it's the most important
it's the best one it's the one you want
to win the MVP the most valuable phone
well not actually valuable value wise
but it's it's really just my favorite
phone of the year at the end of the day
it's come down to like there are really
good phones there are the ones that have
the biggest impact on the industry there
are the ones that are the most fun the
most unique the most Innovative the ones
that have the best features and this one
sort of just combines all of that into
one trophy of recognition for the MVP
the phone of the year for
2023 so what's it going to be I mean
there's been some really interesting
stories there's been some disruptive
phones there's some great phones that
I've enjoyed using my winner for MVP for
phone of the Year
2023 is going to the pixel 8 welld
deserved big shout out to the pixel 8 it
has stepped it up over last year so
there's a bunch of things about this
phone that are genuinely different from
last year but the headlining one the one
that matters the most is it's a $100
more expensive than the pixel 7 so it's
really got to deliver and be a great
phone to be worthy of that and it does
this phone has a great camera not miles
ahead of the rest like previous years
but still an incredible stillest photo
camera it has a dramatically better
display it's stepped up to 120 hzz it's
got this Flagship class 2,000 nits super
bright it also has the same tensor G3
chip as the pro phone which is several
hundred more and also a flagship and
then just a ridiculous amount of
software features again matching the
more expensive pro phone which makes it
harder and harder to justify the pro
phone which I use daily and love but
still for the hundreds of dollars less
this is the way you should probably go
and it's promising now 7 years of
software updates 7 years years of
software updates which is pretty
incredible for a phone so just among all
the things that came out this year as
far as a well-rounded package for impact
for price for stepping it up and being a
really good phone pixel 8 now I do have
a runner up I really again super loved
this phone this year and it's not going
to be a popular phone either but I love
it anyway it's the Asus Zen phone 10
some of youall already know because of
what it did last year how good these
phones are and it does it again in this
weird physics defying package of
basically being nearly perfect small
compact reachable surprisingly good
cameras excellent performance shockingly
good battery life just I don't have a
lot of bad things to say about this
phone Zen phone 10 it's really good you
should watch the full review and I'm
also going to give an honorable mention
to iPhone 15 Pro specifically for
basically now feeling like we've reached
Peak iPhone I know you could have said
this about a lot of previous iPhones but
now that it is USB type c and now that
the notch has been gone for a bit and is
a dynamic Island this just feels like a
finished phone there's not a whole lot
of other things that I'm expecting to
land with a bang on the iPhone maybe a
fingerprint reader or fast charging
maybe that's about it but this is the
best iPhone ever clearly and I feel like
it's finally hit that stride of all
right you've done it two other quick
mentions I do have to give a shout out
an honorable mention to the ultra boring
s23 Ultra just because this is that
phone that is it doesn't have any flaws
it's just a rock solid phone all around
and it consistently gets buried when you
think about the December videos the
phone that came out 12 months ago but I
have to this is a really good phone and
I want to give a shout out to the
OnePlus open for being the foldable
phone that I think I could actually
recommend to real people not that most
people are going to spend 1,800 bucks on
a foldable phone anyway but if you're
going to for one of them this is the
phone that I would daily if you had to
tell me to pick a folding phone today so
shout out to the OnePlus open and uh
that's it that's my smartphone awards
for 2023 so let me know how y'all are
feeling I know there's going to be
comments down below and I can't wait to
hang out and see which ones you would
have picked for your Awards maybe other
people will make their own Awards too
but I'm I'm pretty happy with my list so
until the next one catch you guys later
[Music]
[Applause]
peace